جاءت قرارات الدول المصدره للنفط في
مجموعه اوبيك بلاس خفض انتاجها اليومي
متزامنه في وقت تتوقع فيه انخفاضا في
الطلب خلال الاشهر المقبله فالسعوديه
اعلنت خفض انتاجها بنصف مليون برميل يوميا
بدايه من ايار مايو الى نهايه العام وبقدر
مماثل من حجم الانتاج اعلنت روسيا خفض
انتاجها اليومي بينما اعلن العراق خفضا ب
2011 الف برميل يوميا والامارات ب 144 الف
برميل يوميا اما الكويت فاعلنت خفضا بواقع
128 الف برميل يوميا بينما جاء قرار سلطنه
عمان في حدود 40 الف برميل يوميا واعلنت
الجزائر خفض انتاجها بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل
يضاف هذا الخفض في حجم الانتاج الى الخفض
الذي اعلنته مجموعه اوبك بلاس في اجتماعها
الوزاري الثالث والثلاثين بي فيينا شهر
اكتوبر الماضي الذي قضى حينها بتقليص حجم
الانتاج بم برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام
يتوقع ان يظهر تاثير هذه القرارات في
اسواق النفط الخام بارتفاع محتمل لسعر
البرميل في المرحله المقبله وياتي ذلك
بنقيض ما تريده الولايات المتحده فقد حثت
اداره بايدن المنتجين على ضخ مزيد من
النفط في الاسواق تصف هذه الدول قراراتها
بالاجراء الاحترازي بهدف تحقيق الاستقرار
والتوازن في اسواق النفط الخام ويعتقد
محلل اسواق النفط ان اعلان القرارات جاء
هذه المره بصفه فرديه من كل دوله لتفادي
اي خلاف داخل مجموعه اوبيك بلاس فقد لا
يدعم صغار المنتجين خفضا جديدا يؤثر بشكل
كبير على موازناتهم تجدر الاشاره هنا الى
ان روسيا تواجه قرار دول مجموعه السبع
واستراليا التي فرضت في ديسمبر الماضي حدا
اقصى لسعر النفط الخام الروسي المنقول
بحرا عند 60 دولار للبرميل بهدف الحد من
ايرادات موسكو مع الحفاظ على تدفق نفطها
الى الاسواق العالميه
وتاتي قرارات مصدري النفط في ظرف اقتصادي
دولي اخر يتمثل في ازمه القطاع المصرفي في
الولايات المتحده وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
نتيجه توجهات الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي نحو رفع اسعار الفائده وذاك ما
قد يدفع الامريكيين والاوروبيين نحو سن
قواعد تنظيميه ماليه جديده